from marvel favorites to netflix
thrillers there's a lot of movies that
audiences and critics can't seem to
agree on
video game movies don't have a
reputation for being particularly good
in fact most of them are downright
terrible even if they do tend to make a
profit that's why it wasn't much of a
surprise when uncharted got a poor
rating on rotten tomatoes from critics
even though it wasn't as critically
reviled as the likes of street fighter
or hitman agent 47 based on the video
game series of the same name uncharted
follows the adventures of globetrotting
treasure hunter nathan drake and his
rival mentor victor sully sullivan
unlike the video game in which drake is
a veteran treasure hunter the movie
introduces drake as a newcomer on his
first quest
capitalizing on tom holland's post
spider-man star power uncharted made 147
million dollars domestically and 401
million dollars worldwide not too shabby
still there was a big gap between critic
and audience scores for uncharted with
only 41 percent of professional reviews
being positive many critics lambasted
the casting and compared the movie
unfavorably to adventure films of
decades past really yeah
wow that's your expert analysis on the
other hand about 90 of audiences found
uncharted satisfying thanks to its solid
effects fun fights and relative
similarity to the source material
whichever side you land on the vast
discrepancy between critics and
audiences opinions on this video game
based blockbuster is hardly uncharted
a24 has risen to the top of film
distributors by bringing film goers such
flicks as moonlight green room and ex
machina all films that have united both
critics and audiences but not every 824
film can bridge that gap released in
2016 the monster is an indie horror that
impressed quite a few critics but scared
away general audiences the plot follows
an alcoholic mom and her estranged
daughter as they drive through the woods
on one dark and fateful night that's
when they get into a wreck in the middle
of nowhere and find themselves
confronted by a man-eating creature
mother and daughter are forced to spend
some serious family bonding time
together as they try to survive the
night critics were impressed with the
horror flick from director brian bertino
giving the movie an impressive approval
rating of 80 on rotten tomatoes praise
was heaped upon the film's moody
atmosphere stripped down plot and
ability to balance big emotions with big
scares moviegoers weren't so pleased
though and the film wound up with an
audience score about half as positive a
lot of horror fans found the movie
boring simplistic and predictable and
some were critical of the film's heavy
use of flashbacks so they saddled it
with a 40 positive rating however many
assert that zoe kazan and ella balantine
were impressive as the bickering mother
and daughter it's likely their
performances that kept the divide
between the audiences and critics from
growing any more monstrous
from the snobbiest critic to the most
casual moviegoer everyone loves the coen
brothers for many of their films from
the gut churning no country for old men
to the uproariously funny raising
arizona the gap between audience score
and critics score is practically
non-existent even on the super rare
occasions when the cohen's flop like
with the lady killers audiences and
critics share the hate of course there
are a few exceptions here and there like
intolerable cruelty and the hudsucker
proxy but the most divisive movie of the
cohen's career is almost definitely hail
caesar set in 1950s hollywood this
quirky comedy follows studio fixer eddie
mannix as he tries to calm and corral a
group of unhappy actors and a cadre of
communist writers who've kidnapped the
studio's biggest star while critics
thought the film was divine it seems
that audiences wanted to stab caesar in
the back the audience reaction to this
quippy period piece remains a middling
44 on rotten tomatoes while the critic's
approval rating is much higher at 86
percent most critics adored the loving
parody of the golden age studio system
complete with water aerobics and tap
dancing however it seems the humor
didn't work for most moviegoers and many
wished the plot wasn't so convoluted
would that it was suzanne would the
tutorial
featuring big names like george clooney
channing tatum and scarlett johansson
you'd think everyone would be enamored
with hail caesar but in hollywood few
things are guaranteed
ten years ago a 200 million dollar spy
versus spy action movie starring two
a-list stars would have opened on
thousands of screens these days movies
like that seem to go straight to
streaming that was the case for the grey
man starring ryan gosling and chris
evans gosling plays the cia's number one
agent called 6 who is being hunted down
by a sadistic mustachioed lloyd hansen
played by chris evans this rollicking
ride was directed by the russo brothers
who oversaw captain america the winter
soldier and the third and fourth
avengers films while the grey man had a
limited theatrical release its primary
venue was people's living rooms and
critics weren't impressed nailing the
movie with a rotten rating of 46
but you know who did like it the
audience which gave the movie a score of
90 percent when it came to the critical
response there were no shades of gray
when it came to the gray man critic and
audience opinions were clearly black and
white
did anyone really think that saw 3d
would actually be the final chapter of
the saw franchise in 2017 fans were
tossed back into the world of deadly
puzzles and terrible torture devices
with jigsaw the eighth installment in
the iconic series it seems that seven
year break in between films was a pretty
good move on the part of twisted
pitchers as the audience approval rating
on rotten tomatoes skyrocketed all the
way to the series highest at 89 percent
saw fans were glad to have john cramer
back appreciated all the new traps and
raved about all the films twists and
turns it goes without saying that
critics weren't too keen on jigsaw's
return in fact they haven't really been
nuts about the franchise as a whole
while audiences appreciated the plot
twists critics seemed to find them dull
they also didn't really enjoy the
killer's traps which they didn't find to
be terribly unique or groundbreaking
more than anything though most critics
were just bored that's how the film
ended up with a measly critic score of
32 percent
you've been weighing in on the wrong
side of the scale
harry potter is the highest grossing
book to movie adaptation of all time
with the film franchise having grossed
nearly 10 billion dollars total in the
worldwide box office critics loved the
cinematic adventures of harry hermione
and ron with all eight films in the
original series being certified fresh
the fantastic beasts prequel set decades
before the boy wizard's birth however
they didn't fare well the second film in
the spin-off series 2018's fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald earned
rotten reviews from both critics and
fans it still earned money though
approximately 654 million dollars on a
200 million dollar budget to be precise
however that much fan antipathy is never
a good sign for a franchise moving
forward and something was clearly rotten
in the wizarding world warner brothers
still went full speed ahead with the
third film 2022's fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore which garnered
lousy reviews and critics scores of 46
on rotten tomatoes it also made much
less than its predecessor just 405
million dollars worldwide on a 200
million dollar budget still the
moviegoers who did see dumbledore seem
to enjoy it giving it a much higher
consensus score of 83 percent the film
is hardly spellbinding but still
relatively solid especially coming off
the universally reviled the crimes of
grindelwald
directed by ryan johnson star wars the
last jedi follows the continued
adventures of rey finn and poe as they
try their best to outrun the first order
defeat kylo ren and bring a grizzled
luke skywalker out of retirement
needless to say the film earned tons of
cash but despite all that money this
space opera quickly became one of the
most controversial blockbusters ever
made the fan backlash to the last jedi
was intense and vitriolic providing the
film with a shockingly low audience
score of 42 on rotten tomatoes so what
caused all the ill will toward ryan
johnson sci-fi flick some criticized it
for supposedly being too politically
correct while others simply found the
tone uneven however the biggest
complaint was how the film turned luke
skywalker into a bitter old man who's
given up on the force while some
audiences were appalled with episode 8
critics went crazy for johnson's
addition to the series giving the movie
an extremely fresh rating of 91 percent
fans may have been upset with luke but
critics thought the jedi's new character
arc was a breath of fresh air of course
despite the divided reaction the only
thing disney really cared about was the
1.3 billion dollars the film earned at
the box office
with more than 27 billion dollars in
worldwide grosses and nearly across the
board fresh critic and audience scores
on rotten tomatoes the marvel cinematic
universe has enough clout to take risks
now and then or so marvel studios
thought one risk they took that didn't
pay off was eternals which boasts the
worst critic score in the mcu by a
significant margin the chloe zao film
follows the millennial long adventures
of the eternals god-like beings who
protect the people of earth from bizarre
creatures called deviants the mcu is
pretty much critic proof but eternals
proved to be the exception when it
earned the mcu's one and only cinematic
rotten with a 47 percent from critics
that is as moviegoers kind of liked it
giving eternals a 77 audience score
that's higher than even iron man 2 thor
and captain america the first avenger
when you love something
you protect it
it is
the most natural thing in the world
however the world voted with their
wallets and eternals earned a meager 164
million dollars domestic and 402 million
dollars worldwide on a 200 million
dollar budget surprising no one when
marvel dropped its plans for phases 5
and 6 at san diego comic-con eternals 2
wasn't on the lineup hollywood loves
making movies about the holocaust and as
a result audiences have become
enraptured by films like schindler's
list and the pianist however with all
that attention on nazi war crimes there
are a lot of atrocities that don't get
the hollywood spotlight for example
there aren't many movies about the
armenian genocide in which the ottoman
empire murdered 1.5 million armenians
from 1915 to the early 1920s director
terry george however hoped to right that
wrong by bringing some attention to the
much neglected tragedy in the promise a
2016 film starring oscar isaac christian
bale and charlotte labonne while it
seems the film's audience score on
rotten tomatoes was initially hit by
genocide deniers looking to sabotage the
film the approval rating eventually
bounced all the way up to 92 percent it
seems film fans were impressed by the
film's epic scope and many considered it
an important movie for shedding light on
an oft-forgotten event but critics were
far less kind especially in regards to
the love triangle between isaac vale and
lebon as a result the critic's score
sits far lower at 51
after topher grace debuted a forgettable
venom in spider-man 3 fans of the
character had to wait years for somebody
to do their beloved anti-hero justice it
took over a decade for tom hardy to come
along in 2018 and finally give the
iconic symbiote his title role in venom
around 80 percent of audiences enjoyed
tom hardy's performance agreed the
action sequences were awesome and seemed
to appreciate the film's sense of humor
that wasn't the case for the critics
though without spider-man in sight they
decided venom wasn't worth their time
only 30 percent of professional
reviewers seem to have enjoyed the
adventures of eddie brock and his goopy
parasite parasite yeah it's the term of
endearment that's all apologize no
apologize all right fine
while fans thought the movie was full of
laughs critics were actually bothered by
the movie's tone or lack thereof one of
their biggest critiques was how the film
jumped from comedy to horror to romance
without ever really settling on one
genre however the critics and the fans
did agree on one aspect everybody wished
the movie could have been a little more
r rated
shot on a shoestring budget mohawk is an
indie revenge thriller that follows two
native americans and a british soldier
who are forced to fight for their lives
after ticking off a band of bloodthirsty
settlers even though the movie has some
awesome kills and veers into horror
territory it didn't exactly impress the
average viewer the movie currently sits
at a rather sad audience score of 32
percent on rotten tomatoes so what
didn't moviegoers like about this brutal
revenge flick well some were turned off
by the film's low budget while others
thought the acting was shoddy and over
the top that didn't stop critics from
giving it plenty of praise though in
addition to sticking up for the actors
critics felt there was a lot going on
beneath the surface of mohawk applauding
it for its brutal look at america's
bloody past as a result mohawk won a
very positive approval rating from
critics ending up at 84 percent fresh
it might be hard to believe that a 200
million dollar blockbuster starring
dwayne johnson ryan reynolds and gal
gadot would be a made for tv movie but
in the streaming era things are changing
rapidly released in november 2021 red
notice is a netflix original in which
johnson plays an interpol agent forced
to partner up with his old adversary
reynolds wisecracking art thief to track
down gadot's
we're not partners this is a marriage of
convenience i want a divorce i'm keeping
the kids hilarity and explosions ensue
in a movie that would have likely topped
the box office charts had it been
released theatrically instead it topped
the streaming charts becoming one of
netflix's most watched movies of all
time much to critical dismay red notice
earned a downright rotten score and 36
positive ratings from critics with many
being disappointed by the sum of its
parts you know who wasn't disappointed
though the millions upon millions of
people who streamed it audiences gave
red notice incredible reviews and a 92
percent score applauding its comedy and
narrative twists it's hard to say how
much cash red notice would have earned
if it had been released theatrically but
based on its strong audience reviews and
stacked star power it wouldn't have been
wise to bet against it
based on the mega popular video game
franchise warcraft was a major failure
at the domestic box office earning 47
million dollars against its 160 million
dollar budget luckily for executives the
movie fared much better overseas pulling
in a worldwide total of 439 million
dollars evidently video game fans around
the planet banded together to give
warcraft a reasonably impressive
audience score of 76 on rotten tomatoes
fans of the film have admitted that the
acting is subpar but they were blown
away by the movie's visual effects
especially when it came to the cgi orcs
despite all the computer-generated magic
critics weren't buying what director
duncan jones was selling and gave the
movie a staggeringly awful rotten tomato
score of 29 as a result as it turns out
critics weren't as willing to forgive
the bad acting as audiences were and
they were especially critical of the
lack of well-developed characters
another roadblock was the extensive
mythology of the world of warcraft it
might have been appealing to people
who'd been playing the games for years
but according to critics all that
emphasis on lore just wasn't going to
work for anyone who hadn't already put
their hours in
when bright hit netflix in 2017 the
streaming service had a major hit on its
hands over 11 million people watched the
fantasy buddy cop thriller over its
debut weekend and the film quickly
became one of the most watched originals
in netflix history starring will smith
and joel edgerton the movie follows two
police officers one a human and one in
orc as they're drawn into a mystical
plot involving elves gangs and a
powerful magic wand netflix viewers seem
to adore this weird mishmash of genres
giving bright a commendable audience
score of 83 percent according to the
audience reviews on rotten tomatoes
people thought the urban fantasy world
created by director david ayers and
screenwriter max landis was pretty
phenomenal critics couldn't have
disagreed more though as they called the
screenplay weak and the allegory
hamfisted by the time the critical dust
had settled bright found itself reeling
from both skating reviews and a rotten
tomatoes critic score of 27 to match it
seems that while audiences were enamored
with this world of fairies and
firefights critics found the film empty
lazy and lacking any sort of magic
despite how well-received tom cruise's
movies often are there's one popular
film from early on in his career that
critics weren't exactly convinced by top
gun
yes sir top gun topped the worldwide
charts in 1986 and earned 357 million
dollars at the box office thanks to its
stellar performance and decades of
playing on saturday afternoons on tnt
tony scott's high flying action flick
has become a generation defining classic
for millions of viewers just not for a
good number of critics top gun has a
mediocre critic score of 58 percent on
rotten tomatoes while its audience score
rests at a much more respectable 83
the critical consensus review on the
website says top gun offers too little
for non-adolescent viewers to chew on
when its characters aren't in the air
well perhaps it was an adolescent
audience who bestowed top gun with
strong reviews quite a bit higher than
the critics to show that there were no
hard feelings and prove that time does
indeed heal all wounds the 36 years
later legacy sequel top gun maverick
earned near-perfect rotten tomatoes
reviews from both fans and critics
[Music]
you